Medieval legends have a way of standing the
test of time.
From Arthurian literature to Monty Python
and The Holy Grail, the legend of the black
knight has managed to survive in countless
forms throughout the centuries.
Typically portrayed as a villainous, mysterious
character, the black knight often masks their
identity and swears fealty to no lord or lady
like other knights do.
Under the shroud of anonymity, a black knight
will conduct many a foul deed, usually riding
on the back of a shadowy steed and only ultimately
defeated by their polar opposite, a righteous
white knight, sworn to do good.
A tale as old as time, these two knights of
light and dark are the embodiment of the eternal
moral struggle between good and evil, with
the stock character of the black knight commonly
being associated with death and darkness.These
are just legends, of course.
Or are they?
It has been said that every legend is rooted
somewhere in truth.
While the black knight has always been a metaphorical
figure, a personification of the notion of
evil, could there be a real knight clad in
shadow that first inspired the myth?
Perhaps it’s time you were acquainted with
SCP-5151, who might just be the original Black
Knight himself.
As the name suggests, SCP-5151 is a humanoid
male figure who is originally from the medieval
era.
He sports chainmail armor, specifically a
type called a hauberk, which is chain mail
that forms a full coat or tunic, and he also
wears a laurel wreath around his head.
He often refers to himself as The Black Knight,
although he also claims to have been known
by other names and titles throughout history.
According to observations made by the SCP
Foundation, the Knight never requires food,
water, or rest in order to survive, although
he has been seen to eat and drink purely for
the enjoyment of it.
Even though he appears to wear armor and clothing
beneath, every aspect of SCP-5151’s clothing
and his body share the same anomalous properties.
Every part of him: his armor, his garments,
and his longsword can phase through surfaces
and objects as if the Knight was incorporeal.
SCP-5151 also appears able to alter his physical
properties at will, either becoming solid
or more ghost-like when he so chooses to.
As you can probably imagine, the Foundation
has found it somewhat difficult to contain
The Black Knight thanks to these abilities.
SCP-5151 also possesses an extraordinary method
of attack.
When confronted with a target, the Knight
will deem whether the person is either worthy
or dishonorable, though the criteria he is
judging by seem to be his own mysterious standards.
Should SCP-5151 find someone to be dishonorable,
he will stab them directly through their aorta
with his longsword.
Rather than merely dispatch them though, The
Black Knight will then proceed to drain every
drop of blood from his target’s body, until
they are little more than a dry husk.
This was first witnessed during the Foundation’s
preliminary encounter with SCP-5151.
Alerted to reports of vigilantism taking place
across a number of French provinces, the SCP
Foundation followed this lead to find a trail
of bodies across Alsace, Lorraine, Champagne,
and Orléanais.
The SCP Foundation dispatched one of their
many Mobile Task Forces, MTF Pi-1, also known
under the code name “City Slickers”, to
look into the series of murders.
What they soon found was that these slain
victims were anything but innocent, being
guilty of multiple murders themselves, as
well as the abduction and trafficking of eighteen
children from a French orphanage.
During their investigation, Mobile Task Force
agents discovered the bodies of these criminals
had been killed by exsanguination, the process
of extracting all the blood from their bodies.
The victims possessed matching stab wounds
that pierced their aortas, but forensic analysis
uncovered no traces of blood appearing anywhere
on their clothing.
Acting quickly, the City Slickers apprehended
another man who had been involved in the same
criminal activities as the other two victims,
in the hopes of drawing the killer out into
the open by using the trafficker as bait.
A plan which, as it turned out, would bring
SCP-5151 right to them.
While the Mobile Task Force were transporting
the surviving trafficker, their vehicles were
halted by a figure standing directly in their
path.
As the City Slickers hit their brakes, SCP-5151
began to slowly approach them, ignoring the
agents’ warnings to not step any closer.
One operative opened fire on the approaching
entity, but the conventional arms fire had
no effect on the Knight, with the bullets
passing right through his intangible form.
The Foundation MTF agents instead tried to
restrain SCP-5151, only to find that they
could not physically grab him, their hands
simply passing through The Black Knight’s
body.
Reaching his target, SCP-5151 dispatched of
the remaining criminal in the same way he
had killed the previous two, by stabbing his
longsword directly into the trafficker’s
aorta and rapidly draining the blood from
him.
Then, the Black Knight turned on the operative
that had shot at him, lunging for the Foundation
agent and finishing him in the exact same
way as his other victims.
Immediately after killing the Mobile Task
Force agent SCP-5151 seemed to surrender,
sheathing his weapon and raising his hands
in submission, before offering a greeting
to the remaining members of MTF Pi-1.
“Brave fellows, do not worry about him.
I disposed of him as I have with others of
his lot.
Loyalty is a virtue, and the lack of it will
lead to the death of chivalry.
My presence is a testament that chivalry will
never die.
With this being said, I understand you have
been searching for me.
Pray tell what you might need of me?”
The MTF agents were not about to engage in
a parlay with the ghostly knight and they
contacted command at SCP Foundation Site-06-3.
The Site Director in turn dispatched Doctor
Sylvain Moreau, the Senior Researcher at Site-06-,3
to conduct an on site interview with SCP-5151,
which took place on the roadside where the
Knight had confronted the Mobile Task Force.
Interestingly, not only did SCP-5151 seem
to engage Doctor Moreau with respect and friendly
candor, but he also appeared to be fluent
in French, which the doctor conducted the
interview in.
As they exchanged greetings, the Knight was
compliant with the questions posed to him,
apparently respectful of Moreau’s position
as a doctor.
When asked, SCP-5151 explained that he had
attacked the Foundation agent who had shot
at him because he deemed this individual to
be “worth less than the ground he stood
upon.”
Moreau asked for further clarity on how SCP-5151
determined worthiness, to which The Black
Knight replied by quoting Aeschylus, an Ancient
Greek playwright often known as the Father
of Greek Tragedy.
SCP-5151 claimed “there is no disease that
I spit on more than treachery”, and even
claimed to know Aeschylus personally as a
good man.
Over the course of their conversation, Doctor
Moreau was able to convince SCP-5151 to submit
to containment with the Foundation, however
the Knight made specific requests for his
accommodation.
“I will need plenty of space to practice
my swordplay.
I will also need a retinue to train.
Provide me with your seven best ‘agents’
as you call them.
Men of virtue, brave, and those with reactions
of a white eagle.
I do not intend to deliver my second-best
on any soul during training.
We will train every Tuesday and every Thursday.
We will have a grand banquet to celebrate
our training every Sunday.
The other days, you may use my men as you
see fit, good Doctor.
Comply with my requests, and you shall have
a deal, good Sir!”
The Knight’s requests were approved by the
Site Director of Site-06-3, but before he
submitted to containment, SCP-5151 displayed
another of his anomalous abilities.
The Black Knight requested to make a blood
pact with Doctor Moreau and his group of assistants.
The Senior Researcher reluctantly agreed;
containing an entity that could pass through
walls would be much easier if SCP-5151 was
more cooperative, after all.
Moreau was instructed to slice open his hand
and then accept a handshake from the Knight.
Doing so caused an anomalous marking to form
on the doctor and his researchers’ right
hands at the same time.
When they all held out their hands and compared
the markings, they saw that they were letters
that spelled “honoris”.
Referred to by Foundation researchers as an
instance of SCP-5151-2, this mark caused a
notable burning sensation for Doctor Moreau
and his team as he made his pact with the
Black Knight.
Some of the research assistants also reported
feelings of dread or inadequacy, as well as
an increase in stress levels.
However, it is unknown whether SCP-5151-2
causes these directly, or if these are merely
side effects of this permanent mark appearing
on the skin.
In order to meet the conditions SCP-5151 set
for his containment, the SCP Foundation transferred
him to a cell at Site-06-3.
Any and all electrical devices were banned
from use inside the cell, with the only exception
being a microphone to record audio.
Even the light fixtures were replaced with
oil burning lamps to give The Black Knight’s
“accommodation” a more medieval feel.
The Site Director also authorized the creation
of a completely new Mobile Task Force, designated
as either MTF Pi-7 or the rather appropriate
code name the “Honor Bound Knights”.
This unit was made up of seven of the SCP
Foundation’s finest operatives, hand selected
specifically for their proficiency and skill
in hand to hand combat.
Each member of the Honor Bound Knights wasn’t
just to be a skilled combatant, but also needed
to create a sense of compatibility and rapport
with SCP-5151, given how much time they would
be spending around The Black Knight.
At multiple mornings throughout the week,
every member of the Honor Bound Knights is
instructed to enter the cell of SCP-5151.
Over the course of the next seven long hours,
the Mobile Task Force agents will spar and
train with The Black Knight.
SCP-5151 is known to be a formidable fighter,
believed to have lived for centuries, which
has given him ample time to hone his own skill
with a blade.
Every Sunday evening, after they’ve finished
their long hours of sparring, a wooden table
and chairs are brought into the cell.
Each one of the Honor Bound Knights will then
join SCP-5151, sitting around the table with
him as they share a medieval meal.
Foundation personnel will provide the group
with bread, pies, roasted pig and poultry,
stews and soups, as well as wine.
Together with the seven members of the Honor
Bound Knights, the Black Knight will eat,
drink and revel, until he eventually passes
out.
Then, and only then, are the operatives of
Mobile Task Force Pi-7 permitted to leave
their seats.
It would seem that the Black Knight had exactly
what he wanted most, a loyal group of fellow
warriors to spar against and celebrate with.
However, one member of the unit was noticed
to be acting strangely and was placed under
investigation.
He was discovered to be in possession of several
highly classified SCP Foundation documents,
as well as instructions to abduct an unknown
SCP held in containment.
Site-06-3 staff believed this individual was
working on behalf of the Chaos Insurgency,
a known Group of Interest.
The Foundation has encountered a number of
anomalous groups over its many long years
of pursuing and containing SCPs.
Among them, the Chaos Insurgency is perhaps
the best known.
Formed by former members of the Foundation
itself, the Insurgency rivals the organization
they once defected from, hoping to one day
undermine and destroy it.
While their knowledge of SCPs is more limited,
they are far less restricted by rules and
regulations.
What the Insurgency wanted with The Black
Knight is a mystery, but we’d be willing
to guess that they wouldn’t get on well
with SCP-5151, given his feelings about treachery,
and should the Chaos Insurgency ever get their
way and manage to capture SCP-5151, they might
find that capturing him came with a price
paid in blood.
Now go check out “SCP-2273 - Major Alexei
Belitrov” and “SCP-1879 - Indoor Salesman”
for more strange beings from the SCP Foundation!